The ten-hour surgery was risky and delicate.
Just separating the girls took more than two hours,...
...nearly half of the operation was spent reconstructing their tiny bodies.
But when it was finally over, these conjoined twins from the Philippines...
...emerged in a California hospital as unique individuals for the very first time.
We're very pleased.
Things basically could not have gone better.
Angelina and Angelica Sabuco have never spent a night without the other by her side.
They have never taken a step alone.
Their mother hopes today is the start of a healthy, ordinary life.
The girls were born attached at the chest and abdomen,...
...joined from the middle of the breastbone down to the navel.
They had two hearts but shared a liver.
Separating that organ was the most challenging part of the operation.
It took 20 doctors and nurses from Stanford University's Children's Hospital...
...to help conceive this double dose miracle.
Doctor Gary Hartman who led the team is no stranger to this complicated operation.
This was his sixth separation of conjoined twins.
The girls will spend at least the next week in intensive care...
...and the next few months, rehabilitating their strength.
Their future remains bright.